Over the past century,
astronomers have speculated about the
existence of a mysterious ninth planet
lurking and the outer
reaches of our solar system.
Although we've never directly
observed the elusive planet x,
researchers keep finding more strange
phenomena that seemed to support its
existence.
If this giant planet exists,
what does it look like and how could it
change our understanding of space itself?
This is what if, and here's what
would happen if planet x was real.
Scientists believe that planet x also
referred to as planet nine is about 17
times bigger than earth
and made entirely of gas.
You'd think it would be easy
to spot something so big,
but it orbits the Sun about 10 to
20 times farther away than Pluto.
Finding this planet would teach us
more about how solar systems evolve,
but could it also bring
about the end of days?
[inaudible]
so far,
our hunt for planet x has been mostly
based around the idea of if there's smoke,
there's fire,
and in this case,
the smoke is a bunch of weird
things going on amongst the stars.
In 1972 astronomers noticed
some irregularities in the
course of Halley's comet
detours that they figured were caused
by the gravitational pull of an unseen
distant planet.
Fast forward 10 years to
1982 when scientists were
once again forced to consider
the existence of a hidden planet,
they hypothesized that an unknown outer
planet could be orbiting within our
solar system and causing the orbits of
Uranus and Neptune to deviate from the
laws of physics.
But the most concrete evidence came
in 2014 when astronomers noticed some
distant dwarf planets and IC objects that
all seem to follow orbits that cluster
together.
Upon closer inspection,
they estimated that the powerful
gravitational pull of a hidden planet,
it must've been the cause
of these unusual orbits.
So with all these signs pointing to
the existence and location of planet x,
why haven't we been able to
see it yet? Well, it's really,
really far away and out in space.
Things get dark pretty fast,
okay?
The intensity of the Sun's light weakened
by a factor of four going out and then
four times. Again, reflecting
back to put that in perspective,
a planet that's twice as far away as
our moon would be 16 times fainter.
On top of that,
the planet could be lost in the light
pollution of the Milky Way or the glare of
a bright star,
but with modern technology,
astronomers believe we'll be able
to find planet x in 10 to 15 years.
Deleting team in California uses one
of the most powerful telescopes in the
world and has released a map of where to
look to increase the chances of finding
it through crowdsourced
astronomy. If planted x, Israel,
it would redefine our knowledge of our
solar system's evolution and give us key
insights into how other solar systems
are formed throughout the universe.
Okay.
For as long as serious scientists
have been looking at planet x,
there have been others who have
proclaimed that it's strange orbit will
eventually collide with Earth,
but this has been rejected as nothing
more than pseudoscience and an internet
hoax.
Scientists say that planet x would be
kept well beyond Neptune throughout its
orbit, even when it's closest to the
sun. So even though we can't see it,
it doesn't mean our
ninth planet isn't there.
Maybe one day we'll develop technology
that can identify worlds even further up
than planet x, but that's a
topic for another. What if.